ashley graham is officially a mother of
three really exciting the supermodel
gave birth to her twin boys with husband
justin irvin the two are already proud
parents to their first son isaac who was
born in january 2020. now the newborn
baby boys didn't exactly arrive on their
due date prior to giving birth ashley
let fans know how she was feeling on
tick-tock
baby
yep that's the 34 year old sharing that
at the time she filmed this she was
already five days past due is this like
real life right now ashley announced her
pregnancy on instagram last july and in
september revealed it was not one but
two babies on the way
is that twins yeah
that's a penis that's a peanut and tim
and that's a girl
no it's a boy
you're joking me
jump to new year's day
and the brunette beauty celebrated the
final stretch of her pregnancy ashley
wrote alongside photos of her growing
bump quote made it full term today 40
weeks due dates are just a suggestion
babies will always come on their
birthday prior to the news that she was
expecting two little ones the pretty big
podcast host opened up to e.t about
prepping for their growing family you
know i always heard that number two
you're a lot more tired you show faster
i mean it's happening it's like you know
i start i popped really fast i'm
exhausted i'm running up after a toddler
so yes all the stereotypical things i
don't know if there is much preparation
that can really go in for baby number
two i mean i feel like i did so much
preparation when it came to isaac and
almost to the degree that like i might
maybe over prepared so i'm i'm just
making sure that i have the supplies
that i need which is basically nothing
like i just like i look at my boobs i'm
like okay check check we got this just
need some newborn diapers check check
and um
i'm just not gonna overthink it and when
it comes to little isaac becoming a big
brother ashley says he doesn't fully
understand the concept just yet
i said do you know where the baby is and
then he points to my stomach so we got
that farm and then sometimes he wants to
kiss the baby so he goes like this
he like curls his top lipid and bottom
lip out it's really sweet so we got that
far but i don't think he understands
like the big brother aspect well there's
no doubt isaac will be the best big bro
congratulations to the family of five
[Music]
you